since 2004 Millennials have been voting
increasingly democratic in presidential
elections they're half as likely to
self-identify as politically
conservative and nearly twice as likely
to say they're liberal and this has led
many people to conclude that this is a
democratic generation but despite all of
this Millennials are actually no more
likely than Americans over 32 say
they're Democrats instead they're three
times as likely to say they're
independent and half as likely to say
they're Republican Millennials have
little confidence in either of the two
major political parties especially when
it comes to privacy government spending
the deficit and drug policy however they
do seem to view Democrats as the better
of two bad options and they're really
frustrated with the Republican Party who
they see as being a little bit too far
to the right on social issues the fact
is Millennials aren't liberals they're
social liberals and their fiscal
centrists and their social attitudes are
with largely defining their political
identities and driving their voting
behavior so how do we know that social
issues are largely defining their
political identities well first we ask
them among liberal Millennials only a
third said something about economics
being part of the reason why their
liberal instead two-thirds said
something about social issues social
tolerance is being critical to why they
are liberal second we find that
Millennials see themselves as closer to
President Barack Obama on social issues
no surprise there but they actually see
themselves as closer to New Jersey
Governor Chris Christie who is a
Republican on economic issues
nevertheless they're still voting for
Democrats the third thing is that a
majority of Millennials say that they
would vote for a socially liberal
fiscally conservative candidate some
might call that a libertarian leaning
candidate but the Millennials who are
most supportive of this type of
candidate are liberal and democratic
Millennials in fact liberal Millennials
are 20 points more likely than
conservatives to say that they would
vote for a socially liberal fiscally
conservative candidate these demonstrate
to us that social issues are largely
driving their political judgments
this actually isn't that surprising
because economics just isn't that
salient for this cohort yet and one of
some of the reasons for that are that
they're getting married later and
they're buying homes later and they're
just not paying that much in taxes yet
but once those things inevitably start
to happen economics will matter more to
their political judgments and we may see
a shift in their attitudes towards
government